very common question I get Gary how do I
get my employees to work as hard as I do
my reply on email to make them equal
Partners the way I think about getting
team members on board is by caring more
about their needs than mine people talk
about wanting their employees to be
loyal yet they're not loyal
years old
the first time I worked in my dad's
liquor store
he didn't say a single thing to me on
our 40-minute drive to the store
until we got to the parking lot and then
he turned to me and he looked at me and
he said keep an eye on the employees
they all steal as I'm older now I
understand him at the time I was very
emotional about this for me
my employees are my family I think we
have audacity
at the ownership level at the leadership
level the way I think about getting team
members on board is by caring more about
their needs than mine the way I do it is
through empathy and compassion and
putting myself in their shoes and asking
why would they want to be on board
I reverse engineered their emotional
graph and then on an individual basis
I try to understand where they are on
their Journey
sometimes kids come into my company and
the first time I sit down with them
they say to me one day I'm going to run
this whole company and I'm thrilled I'm
like please I'm getting old you know
that same employee five years later
sometimes walks into my office and says
I need more work-life balance because
now they fell in love and they're
starting a different chapter of their
life and I love that I don't judge them
for not wanting to work 14 hours a day
anymore I respect that that's their
interest I think it's a Leader's
obligation
to reverse engineer the wants and needs
of the people on their team not only
philosophically but in reality on a
day-to-day basis
and I think that's a very
very hard thing to do but I think it's
required to build something big
when you have the intent to care
you ask the questions
you know when people come up with
excuses of why they haven't accomplished
something it's often predicated on the
fact that they didn't want to know the
answer at the time
do you know how many business owners
avoid one-on-one conversations with
their employees because they're scared
they're going to ask for a raise
so that one's very easy it's called
intent
one of the hardest things for a room
like this to do to build scale is
Letting Go
you know people want to micromanage
because they don't realize their ego is
tied up in it
people that start businesses have
incredible pride in being the best at
the thing
to the demise of scale
anytime
someone says that they're not growing to
the level of their ambition or hopes and
dreams
99 out of 100 times it's based on ego
it's their incapable of creating scale
because they fear
scale
because they fear it in two ways one is
a very good one they're scared that if
they're not doing it the client is not
getting the quality of execution that
they're accustomed to
which is coming from a very Noble place
but
is required to make scale
or two they don't realize how much pride
they have in telling everybody that
works for them that they're better at
the thing than all of them both of it
comes from a place of fear you know I
think a lot about that when I
talk to businesses that entrepreneurs
run I'm trying to understand can they
see that fear is dictating them
thus having them on defense versus
offense most entrepreneurs and small
businesses want to win the game one
nothing
[Music]
they don't realize that that's what
they're doing but that's what they're
doing
and I think for me I want to win the
game 17-14
39-32
116 to 104.
most people don't have the appetite to
make 104 mistakes
[Music]